bonjour il ya quelques années j'avais dû
expliquer à une amie que non le blason
de sa vie il ne représentait pas un lion
mais un léopard
quelle déception si comme moi vous
voulez vous la péter en lisant les
blasons des villes de vos amis cet
épisode est fait pour vous vous aurez
peut-être remarqué au passage que j'ai
changé le titre de ce format puisque
avec les créatrices du tube dont on ne
va plus se proposait de thèmes mensuel
mais j'ai quand même envie de continuer
à faire des épisodes des pères dans mon
canapé
donc voilà maintenant ça s'appellera
bulletin profs et ça sera sensiblement
la même chose que les créatrices de
youtube
l'utilisation d'un mari spécifique pour
identifier un chevalier se développe au
12e siècle en raison du changement
d'équipement militaire de ces chevaliers
en effet à cette époque se développent
les côtes de maille et les casques
couvrant le visage et devient donc
nécessaire de les identifier autrement
que par leurs visages grâce à le vrai qu
par exemple leur étendard ou encore à un
signe distinctif que le chevalier porte
au dessus de leur casque lors des
tournois pour faire joli et pour faire
genre qu'ils sont plus grands on
retrouve certaines armary avant le 12ème
siècle comme sur la tapisserie de bayeux
qui date du 11e siècle
on parle alors d'emblème près héraldique
ces anglais ne sont pas héréditaires et
il est peu probable qu'ils aient été
permanent pour ceux qui les utilisent
puisqu'à partir du 12ème siècle les
armoiries de vienne héréditaire elles
deviennent un système d'identification
des personnes mais aussi des lignes et
leur utilité est la même que celle des
sceaux qui permettent d'identifier un
document à une période où beaucoup de
personnes sont illettrés on en arrive
donc au terme des radicaux qui est un
dérivé de la fonction de héros sur
laquelle nous reviendrons juste après
les radigue désigne l'étude des
armoiries et on la qualifie de science
est radié qu'à partir du xviie siècle et
pour faire court le blason n'est pas un
synonyme d'armoiries les armoiries ce
sont les petits dessins sur le bouclier
et le blason ou la zone mans c'est la
description de ses armoiries selon des
termes bien précis donc à gauche ce sont
des armoiries et à droite c'est leur
blason
les armoires et sont particulièrement
utiles lors des tournois des
compétitions entre chevaliers comme les
chevaliers de les montrer qu'ils étaient
courageux
noble et tout le bazar ils allaient de
tournoi en tournoi pour montrer à quel
point les étés balèze les tournois
étaient aussi l'occasion de montrer
leurs armoiries un peu partout pour se
faire connaître
ainsi les accrocher leurs boucliers à
l'extérieur de leur lieu d'habitation et
représenter leurs armoiries un peu
partout sur leur bouclier mais aussi
leurs vêtements le harnachement de leurs
chevaux leur tante leur mauvais souvenir
mais évidemment pour les pécores qui
venaient assister au tournoi et même
pour les personnes de haut rang des
armoiries ne voulait pas dire grand
chose pour les déchiffrer
il fallait à m un expert le héros les
héros c'était cm qui connaissent tout le
monde en soirée ou devient à force de
travail et de voyages des experts en
héraldique et son chargé lors des
tournois d'annoncer personnes qui
arrivent en énonçant son blason puis en
le nommant ils font donc office de
maître de cérémonie mais aussi d'armes
litres et s'assure que personne de
combat sous les armes de quelqu'un
d'autre que chaque armoiries et bien
unique etc
de manière un peu moins fun si un
chevalier désire confier son testament à
quelqu'un avant de commencer le tournoi
c'est au héros qu'il doit s'adresser
leur rôle ne se limite pas au tournoi
ils sont aussi employées par les
personnages importants comme messager et
ambassadeur lorsqu'ils sont en service
il porte un tabac ou co dame une sorte
de tunique en gros aux couleurs de leurs
maîtres
cette cote d'armes les rend
théoriquement intouchables ils sont
libres de circuler partout même dans les
camps ennemis n'ont aucune valeur de
rançon et effectué des missions
diplomatiques comme portée des
déclarations de guerre par exemple toute
attaque faite à leur encontre est une
attaque envers leurs maîtres comme ils
s'y connaissent en héraldique ils sont
aussi utiles lors des combats on leur
demande d'identifier les morts et les
captifs pour savoir s'ils valent cher ou
pas et il arrive même qu'en certaines
occasions de ce soit aux héros de
décider si la bataille a été gagnée ou
pas c'est le cas lors de la bataille
d'azincourt par exemple à partir du 14e
siècle
les héros établissent des arts morio d
ouvrage qui recense toutes les armoires
et qu'elles connaissent pas ce qu'il y
en avait un paquet dans les mémoires de
olivier delamarche qui vécut au 15e
il estime qu'il faut sept ans pour
devenir héros le temps d'acquérir assez
de connaissances en la matière c'est
aussi à partir de cette époque qu'il
codifie les radis qu'avec tous ces
thèmes particuliers et ses règles en
angleterre les héros sont réunis en
corporations par une charte royale 2484
et il leur arrive de faire des visites
d'inspection à travers le pays pour
répertorier les armoiries et régler les
conflits dans certains pays comme
l'angleterre les héros existe encore
donc aux fonctions de confirmer des
armoiries utilisé par une famille depuis
longtemps mais qu'il n'aurait jamais été
officialisée ou encore de créer de
nouvelles armoiries pour certaines
familles par exemple le collège des
armes d'angleterre a accordé des
armoiries à la famille middleton au
moment du mariage de kate middleton en
la famille s'est vue attribuer des armes
d'azur palais de gueule aux chevrons
d'orques otis et d'argent accompagné de
trois glands d'or tiges et effeuillée du
mmm et chaque détail a un sens
particulier les trois glands
représentent les trois enfants ce super
flatteur dit comme ça mais aussi la
région dans laquelle la famille agrandie
parce que c'est une région du clan enfin
il ya beaucoup de chaînes les chevrons
d'argent représente des collines parce
qu'ils adorent la nature le chevron d'or
représente la mère de kate dont le
nombre de naissances est goldsmith etc
bref les armoiries ne sont pas juste là
pour faire joli mais ont souvent un sens
plus ou moins évident
c'est ce que nous allons détailler à
présent on va surtout s'intéresser à
l'écu au bouclier
parce que c'est la partie principale des
armoiries est la seule qui soit
indispensable
certaines armes sont décorées avec des
petits comme des banderoles etc terrain
mais on ne va pas s'attarder là dessus
alors pour commencer simplement en
langage de l'héraldique la gauche
sénestre et la droite
dextre doivent être prises du point de
vue de la personne qui tient le bouclier
elles sont donc inversés par rapport à
d'habitude le bouclier est aussi divisée
en cinq régions principales le chef le
coeur les flancs dextre et sénestre et
la pointe
ces régions renvoie à des parties du
corps puisqu'on est sur des histoires de
gauche et de droite
la dextre étant considérée comme la
direction la plus noble
n'en déplaise aux gauchers la plupart
des emblèmes sont dessinés tourner vers
ce côté
passons aux couleurs à présent il existe
trois catégories de couleur en
héraldique d'ailleurs on éradique on ne
parle pas de couleurs mais des mots
comme le noir
parce que le noir s'est troué mots bref
il existe des tas de termes compliqués
en éradiquer c'est que le début il ya
d'abord les émaux qui font référence à
des couleurs gueule pour rouge azur ou
bleu céleste pour ben le sable pour noir
pour pour viol et tanner pour marans
sinople pour vert et orange et où
centimes pour de l'orangé sanguinaire
ensuite il existe 2 et mots issus de
métaux or pour jaune et argent pour
blanc on peut vraiment les représentés
par de l'or et de l'argent mais ces
pigments coûte cher alors ils sont plus
souvent représentée par du jaune et du
blanc et enfin les émaux issus de
fourrure l'hermine avec toutes ces
variations contre hermine contre hermine
et et le r ouvert composé de petites
pièces on forme de clochettes mais aussi
à des variations vers et contre vers
menu vers beffroi vert par rapport à
tous ces mots il ya des règles à
respecter
jamais de métal sur métal ni de couleur
sur couleur ni de fourrure sur fourrure
bien sûr il ya des exceptions comme les
armes de la ville de jérusalem qui sont
hors sur argent quand des armoiries ne
respectent pas cette règle
elles sont dites à anker maintenant
qu'on a vu les couleurs passons aux
partitions de l'écu la couleur dans
laquelle il est peint s'appelle le champ
mais cette équipe peut être divisé on
parle alors de partitions peut-être
partie écartelé en sautoir écartelé
gironné tiercé en perles ou paix
tranches étalées manque les 10 comme ça
on dirait qu'on a bien fait souffrir ce
pauvre et qu la division en quartiers
dans le cade armoiries royales ou
princières peut par exemple servir à
montrer qu'on possède plusieurs
territoires
s'il s'agit d'un mari personnel il peut
s'agir d'un regroupement de familles les
lignes de partition ne sont pas
forcément droite
elles peuvent être par exemple crénelés
donc les engrais les ondes voyez
potencée etc
jusqu'ici si on devait blasonnés ctq par
exemple on commencerait par décrire les
divisions du chant la forme de la ligne
si elle n'est pas droite puis les
couleurs en commençant en eau à
d'extraits on a donc un blason parti sur
fond or
enfin viennent les meubles c'est à dire
toutes les pièces qu'on va rajouter sur
nos armoiries il ya déjà les petites
pièces sympa et pas compliqué à dessiner
comme les croix chevron bordure bande
barbate ont péri en bande face sautoir
chef mon jeu pas toutes les citer parce
qu'on en a un paquet passons aux
meilleurs animaux jusqu'au 16e siècle ce
sont les principales figures employés
même si on utilise ensuite certains
objets inanimés
on trouve les animaux classique que vous
avez forcément déjà vu l'aigle le cerle
sangliers cf game of thrones pour la
liste complète
parmi eux le lion est très répandu pour
son caractère noble est féroce
c'est le roi des animaux il peut avoir
des positions spécifiques
on parle de lyon passe en couches est
accroupi ou deux lionceaux s'il y en a
trois ou plus parfois on lui fait porter
des couronnes des colliers voire même
des attributs chimérique comme dlc
griffé sa langue sont toujours rouges
sauf si le fond est rouge dans ce cas
elles sont souvent bleu il devrait
consulter un veto par contre comme je le
disais pour la normandie
si le lion vous regarde droit dans les
yeux c'est un léopard certaines armoires
y représentent aussi des êtres
monstrueux comme la mandragore dans les
radis qu'anglaise la sirène mélusine le
centaure le sphinx égyptien où le sphynx
grecque et enfin l'homme sirène et l'âme
anticorps qui sont plus rares en
héraldique est dans la vraie vie aussi
enfin perso j'en ai jamais croisés enfin
la dernière catégorie des animaux
correspond aux animaux chimérique par
exemple l'antilope est une invention
anglaise qui représentait par un dragon
rampant avec des cornes de cerf et sans
elle on voit que les gars connaissais
pas trop l'afrique
on trouve aussi le dragon qui a des
ailes en angleterre mais pas en france
en france le dragon ailé est en fait un
amphi pts r oui c'est une erreur
courante
il y a aussi le phénix la salamandre les
halles et la licorne trop chou pis
encore une fois cette liste est non
exhaustive les possibilités de mélange
d'animaux et de meubles à utiliser sont
très nombreuses il ya aussi le griffon
par exemple lui c'est le roi de toutes
les créatures parce que le lion est le
roi des animaux
l'aigle est le roi des oiseaux et le
griffon est un mélange des deux
d'ailleurs on éradique seule la femelle
adl le malade et défense et des pics sur
le dos parce que c'est plus badass
il y a aussi des thèmes particuliers si
les animaux ont des becs des griffes des
camps par exemple on dit qu'ils sont
armés ils peuvent aussi être adossé ces
jeux se fondent au affronter s'ils se
font face essilor que passe sous leur
ventre il son poids ils peuvent aussi
être à deux ou trois corps ou encore
coupé arraché si des lambeaux de chair
pendent bon appétit en plus des animaux
les meubles courant du début de
l'héraldique peuvent être des fleurs
comme le lis la rose ou de chardons ou
encore quelques objets inanimés tels que
les tours pontchâteau et autres
bâtiments
voilà j'ai pas testé tous les termes
mais une bonne partie
maintenant vous allez pouvoir blasonnés
découvrir et d armor et quelque part je
compte sur vous comme les armoiries sont
héréditaires les fils de notre seigneur
lambda appelons le jacou et ajouteront
des petits détails sur dans un mari pour
se différencier de leurs pairs on
appelle cela des brisures parce que ça
lui les brise donc maman lorsque le fils
aîné atteint la majorité et la joute des
petites brisure sur son haouari et
lorsque son père meurt une les enlève
parce que maintenant c'est lui le patron
s'il montre le fils suivant peut à son
tour viré c'est brisure et devenir le
chef de famille imaginons maintenant que
notre ami jacques où il n'a que des
filles si elles ne se marie pas elles
peuvent quand même porter ces armes
jusqu'à leur mort et ça c'est classe si
l'une des filles se marient son mari
peut ajouter les armes de la famille
jacou aux siennes on appelle ça le
relèvement d'armes et c'est ce cas de
figure qui amène à des divisions
toujours plus compliqué ans
partie puis en quartier que encore plus
de quartier aux xviie et xviiie siècles
surtout ça devient la mode de
représenter toutes les alliances et
ascendance possible et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on parle de quartiers de
noblesse et ça devient donc le bordel
par exemple le sto auriol pas en 1806
pour richard tant que granville est un
exemple d'armes sur composé par contre
si les filles de jacques où se marient
avec des types qui n'avaient pas d'armes
houari en théorie ces morts elles ne
pourront pas les transmettre
même si dans les faits ça se faisait
quand même enfin si un mec exercent des
fonctions particulières évêque par
exemple il peut ajouter les armoiries de
ses fonctions à ses armoiries
personnelles et s'il fait partie d'un
ordre il peut ajouter une banderole sous
ses armoiries avec la devise de cet
ordre dont c'était bien compliqué mais
pour retenir l'essentiel l'héraldique
c'est compliqué il ya plein de rêves et
tout autant d'exceptions en faisant mes
recherches j'ai même découvert que le
collage des armes d'angleterre avait
publié un texte de loi en 2014 qui
expliquait le principe de transmission
des armoiries dans le cadre d'un mariage
entre deux personnes de même sexe et ça
c'est bien au fil des siècles les
armoiries ne se limite plus seulement
aux chevaliers et à la noblesse des
femmes des clercs des bourgeois voire
même artisan ou paysans ce sens font
aussi les armoiries deviennent également
utilisée pour représenter les
corporations de métiers des communautés
religieuses des universités ou même des
villes pourtant verdict a perdu son
usage initial à partir du 14e siècle
avec l'invention de la poudre les
armures ne faisons plus trop le poids
face aux projectiles des armes à feu les
combattants sont donc de nouveau
identifiables sans les armoiries sur le
champ de bataille mais les armoiries
sont entre temps devenu un symbole de
reconnaissance pour l'ensemble de la
société et plus seulement sur des
tournois par exemple une récompense
possible d'un monarque envers son sujet
était d'augmenter ses armoiries en y
ajoutant un petit détail
perso j'ai vu mieux comme récompense
même si ça leur faisait plaisir
on va même créé des armoires et
imaginaire pour des personnages qui
n'avait rien à voir avec tout ça
existait avant l'apparition des
armoiries par exemple alexandre jules
césar ou charlemagne ou encore pour des
personnages qui ne font même pas partie
de l'occident chrétien
attila a eu six mois riz par exemple on
en invente pour des personnages issus de
la mythologie gréco romaine où la
mythologie scandinave des personnages
bibliques littéraire comme roland le roi
arthur
si vous croisez un jour quelqu'un
portant ses armoiries fuyez c'est satan
bref tout le monde a ses armoiries c'est
merveilleux et puisque c'est comme ça
moi aussi j'en veux voilà de sinople et
d'or accompagnée d'un orque sable et
argent ça en jette ou pas merci d'avoir
regarder cet épisode je vous dis à
bientôt pour le mois de mai où je
libérerait avis lors de son placard pour
réaliser un nouvel épisode de chroniques
de profs
en attendant on se retrouve sur les
réseaux sociaux et si vous n'avez pas
suivi d'ailleurs toujours sur ces
réseaux sociaux
je serai à montbazon au festival les
historiques cet été les 22 23 juillet
enfin vous retrouverez toutes les
informations
après dans la description voilà voilà
et ça sera bien alors à bientôt
[Musique]
on